de Nika is with us in Tacoma Washington
hi Danica how are you good thank you are
you better than I deserve what's up okay
so I my question was we're looking to
move into a different rental and people
are saying well why don't you just buy
so what is your argument against renting
versus buying when your rent it can be
more if not the same as a mortgage taxes
and house or like house in short house
insurance
well renting if the payment is similar
is cheaper because you don't have
increases in insurance and taxes and you
don't have maintenance see if you buy a
home and your payments the same and the
heating air goes out that's a $5,000
item if you rent a home and your
payment's the same and heating air goes
out the landlord fixes it so that that's
the reality so often times on the short
run owning a home is not cheaper even if
the payment is cheaper than renting
because you've got maintenance and other
issues involved you have to do all the
stuff that really I mean if you look
down and roaches run across the floor
you got to call an exterminator and
you're going to pay several hundred
dollars maybe and you know you're not
going to you if you look down roaches
run across the floor and you know you
call your landlord if you're a renter so
there's all these things that people
don't think about
I believe in homeownership and I want
you to and over the course of your life
you know over the course of a lengthy
period of time it's there but monthly
cash flow it's never cheaper to own and
you know unless of course you paid 100
percent down and you know you own the
thing and you have no payment at all but
I'm saying you know if you're trying to
compare payments like that now I do want
you to move towards owning a home and we
teach people to do that in a way where
the home is a blessing and not a curse
when you buy a house you can't afford
when broke people buy a house you know
it makes make some broker because of
what I'm talking about here and so you
know when you have no money and you buy
a house the house is a curse you don't
want to do that so I want you to get out
of that have a good emergency fund of
three to six months of
offences and then have a good down
payment before you buy and then when you
buy the house will be a blessing but if
you move in that house and you got a
student loan and you got a car payment
and you have zero money and you just
barely got in with some kind of creative
financing crap as soon as you move in
the dishwasher will go out the next week
the heat and air will go out I mean
you're asking for your life to look like
a country song in the same barn your
antes del house would like the two-year
house warranties don't cover that kind
of stuff if you looking for a warranty
oh I don't care I mean they they cover
some things but you're going to pay for
that too right that's not free and so
you know you're going to get yourself in
a mess if you buy a house when you're
broke so get get yourself squared around
get a good solid foundation under you
three to six months of expenses save for
emergencies plus a down payment and be
debt free and then the house will be a
blessing put it on a 15 year or less
where the payment is on a fixed rate
where the payment is no more than 1/4 of
your take-home pay and then the house
will go up in value and if you have some
monthly costs and it cost you a little
bit more this year and next year then
renting would have cost you it's okay
you'll get it back in the long run
because as rents go up yours won't go up
you know you don't have the increases
and you know you'll be able to you'll be
able to reap the rewards of
homeownership as the value goes up of
course later on but but just don't
believe the mythology that the cash flow
is as simple as comparing rent to your
payment there's a lot more to it than
that and that's very a very naive math
formula that people use to rationalize
and justify the fact that they got house
fever and I want to buy a house on about
house on the by house and you know I
believe in houses I want you to get a
house just don't want your house to get
you
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you